as I've been hiding something I've been  high honor I'm literally trying to tell  you guys something that will positively  change your lives okay I found the  roller world money I need protection and  protection from what  200 K in this neighborhood who wouldn't  be paranoid  [Music]  it's a new year  finally we could get back to normal big  feelings they're good  that's the gift of use that's it  everybody  [Music]  but our teenage boys finally stick it in  do you love him does he love you didn't  he say it yeah why are you talking like  that  why are you [ __ ] be monkish this is  free-range should happen stinking Oh  give me my pen  I don't want to live the rest of my life  in fear a winter Brett  every day we can choose to love is that  a hey I'm gonna focus on the good  [Applause]  [Music]  wakey-wakey [ __ ]  you